♪ ♪
>> Laura: AILING JOHN McCAIN
IS ONCE AGAIN THE MEDIA'S
FAVORITE REPUBLICAN.
NOW THAT HE REPORTEDLY DOES NOT
WANT PRESIDENT TRUMP AT HIS
FUNERAL AND HE ALSO WISHES HE
HADN'T PICKED SARAH PALIN AS HIS
RUNNING MATE BACK IN 2008.
BUT HIS FONDNESS FOR THE MEDIA
HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN A TWO-WAY
STREET AS THEY ROUTINELY HAVE
TRASHED HIM WHEN IT SUITS THEIR
OWN PURPOSES.
IN A 2006 ARTICLE HEADLINED
JOHN McCAIN, THE SELLOUT, THE
POST CALLED THE SENATOR A
POLITICIAN WHO WILL STOP AT
NOTHING TO GET ELECTED.
McCAIN 'HAS GREAT SIN?
AGREEING TO SPEAK AT JERRY
FALWELL'S LIBERTY UNIVERSITY.
THE ATLANTIC RAN A PIECE DURING
THE 2008 PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
TITLED McCAIN, THE SELLOUT.
BASED ON A FEAR THAT THE
CANDIDATE MIGHT GOVERN AS A
CONSERVATIVE.
AND IN A 2010 "VANITY FAIR"
PIECE HEADLINED THE MAN WHO
NEVER WAS, McCAIN IS CALLED SO
DESPERATE TO KEEP HIS SENTENCE'S
DESPERATE TO KEEP HIS SENTENCE'N
DESPERATE TO KEEP HIS SENTENCE'T
DESPERATE TO KEEP HIS SENTENCE'E
SEAT THAT HE REPUDIATED HIS
RECORD, HIS PRINCIPLES AND EVEN
HIS MAVERICK REPETITION.
ENTRENCHING HIMSELF AS THE
ANTI-OBAMA.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT McCAIN, A
P.O.W. WITH HIM DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR.
A P.O.W. FOR SIX YEARS AND ALSO
MY COLLEAGUE IN THE REAGAN
ADMINISTRATION.
AND FRANK, ESTEEMED POLLSTER.
HE'S GOING TO SHOW HOW THE MEDIA
HAVE USED McCAIN OVER THE
YEARS TO FIT WHATEVER NARRATIVE
THEY FIND CONVENIENT AT THE
MOMENT.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
JIM, I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
FIRST.
FIRST OF ALL, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I WAS YOUNG, YOU WERE EVEN MORE
HANDSOME BACK THEN BACK IN 1987,
SHARING OFFICE TOGETHER.
>> THAT'S BEFORE I TOOK ON THE
APPEARANCE OF A HOMELESS MAN.
>> Laura: IT'S ALL COOL HERE.
YOU BETTER THAN ANYONE KNOW THE
EXPERIENCE THAT JOHN McCAIN
HAD IN VIETNAM.
YOU'VE KNOWN HIM FOR A LONG,
LONG TIME.
I KNOW YOU HAVEN'T SEEN HIM FOR
A WHILE.
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU THAT HE AT
THE END DECIDED IT WAS GOING TO
MAKE HIS FUNERAL PLANS AND MAKE
IT EXPLICIT THAT TRUMP WAS NOT
TO BE THERE?
>> YES IT DOES.
I DON'T KNOW HOW FAR ADVANCED
THIS CANCER IS, BUT I KNOW
THAT -- I WAS TOLD THAT IT IS
VERY AGGRESSIVE.
TO SAY THAT THINGS LIKE HE DID
ABOUT SARAH PALIN, LOOK, I WAS
WITH HIM.
I WARMED UP AN AUDIENCE FOR HIM
THE DAY AFTER THE CONVENTION IN
A BIG RALLY NORTH OF DETROIT AND
HE TRIED TO INTRODUCE ME TO
SARAH PALIN AND WE COULDN'T GET
NEAR HER BECAUSE SHE WAS JUST
MOBBED BY PEOPLE.
HE WAS THERE WHEN HE INTRODUCED
HER AND HE SAW THE ELECTRICITY.
I WILL TELL YOU HOW IT AFFECTED
US.
WE WERE UP IN THE BOOTH.
I TURNED TO MY LEFT AND I WAS
SITTING NEXT TO THE MOST
DECORATED AMERICAN WARRIOR AND
ALL OF HISTORY AND BUD HAD TEARS
IN HIS EYES.
HE WAS SO MOVED.
THAT'S THE EFFECT SHE HAD.
SO FOR HIM TO BE DOING THAT --
I'M NOT GOING TO HOLD ANYTHING
AGAINST JOHN FOR WHAT HE SAYS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH THAT HAS
AFFECTED HIM, BUT THE JOHN THAT
I KNOW WAS ONE OF THE GREATEST
HEROES I EVER KNEW AND ONE OF
THE FINEST MEN I EVER KNEW.
>> Laura: FRANK, IT IS
INTERESTING TO GO BACK AND SEE
THOSE HEADLINES FROM ALL OF THE
ELITE PUBLICATIONS,
JOHN McCAIN THE SELLOUT,
JOHN McCAIN THE PHONY FRAUD,
ALL THE THINGS THEY SAID, BUT
NOW HE'S HITTING TRUMP AND HE
HAS OBVIOUSLY BEEN AT ODDS WITH
TRUMP ON A NUMBER OF POLICIES,
IMMIGRATION, FOREIGN POLICY TO
NAME A FEW, AND NOW NOT JUST
BECAUSE I THINK HE'S OBVIOUSLY
SUFFERING TERRIBLY, I'VE LOST
THREE FRIENDS TO THIS IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS, IT'S A
HORRIFIC DISEASE.
YOU SEE THE EBB AND FLOW OF
THEIR RELATIONSHIP.
>> IT HAPPENED IN 2000 WHEN HE
WAS RUNNING AGAINST W.
IT HAPPENED IN 2008 WITH
MITT ROMNEY, SO THIS IS NOTHING
NEW.
JOHN McCAIN UNDERSTOOD HOW TO
USE THE PRESS TO HIS OWN
ADVANTAGE.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY HE'S
SUCH A GOOD POLITICIAN.
BY THE WAY, I WANT YOU TO KNOW
IT IS AN HONOR TO SIT NEXT TO
YOU AND FRANKLY I FEEL THE SAME
WAY ABOUT ANY OF THESE MEN.
THEY SUFFERED, TRULY SUFFERED IN
PRISONER OF WAR.
DONALD TRUMP, I DON'T KNOW WHO
YOU REMEMBER, I WAS ASKING
QUESTIONS IN
IOWA AND MY INTERVIEWER SAID
THAT JOHN McCAIN IS NOT A WAR
HERO.
HE WALKED THAT BACK WHEN YOU'RE
ON.
BUT McCAIN AND THE PRESS.
IT SEEMS LIKE A PRETTY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHAT CNN
SAID TODAY, LET'S WATCH.
>> HE IS NOT A SELLOUT AND I
THINK HAVING PRESIDENT TRUMP,
JUST BECAUSE HE IS THE PRESIDENT
COME AND SPEAK ON HIS BEHALF OR
EULOGIZE HIM OR MEMORIALIZE HIM
WOULD BE SELLING OUT.
SENATOR MCCAIN, I SAY THIS NOT
JUST AS IT IS DAUGHTER'S PLAN,
BUT AS A REPUBLICAN WHO
SUPPORTED HIM, SENATOR MCCAIN IS
EVERYTHING THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS NOT.
>> I HAVE TO SAY THAT SOMEBODY
SHOULD HAVE PULLED DONALD TRUMP
BEFORE HE SAID THAT ABOUT JOHN.
JOHN EJECTED AND HIS AIRPLANE
WAS JUST DISINTEGRATED.
ONE OF THE WINGS CAME OFF AND AS
SOON AS HIS CHUTE OPENED THE
WING SWUNG AROUND, BROKE BOTH OF
HIS ARMS AND ONE OF HIS LEGS, SO
I DON'T KNOW HOW HE WAS ABLE TO
OPEN UP -- MUCH LESS HOW HE
COULD SWIM.
I HAVE NO IDEA HOW HE SURVIVED
BUT I KNOW THAT HE COULD NOT
POSSIBLY HAVE DONE ANY
RESISTANCE BECAUSE HE WAS
HELPLESS FOR SEVERAL WEEKS AFTER
THAT.
BUD DAY HAD TO TAKE CARE OF HIM.
BUD DAY HAD TO FEED HIM.
>> Laura: COULD YOU HEAR HIM
WHERE YOU WERE IN THE HEALTH AND
WHERE YOU WERE IN THE HEALTH AN
AND?
>> I LIVED WITH HIM FOR TWO
YEARS.
>> Laura: YOU ARE SEPARATED --
YOU WERE THERE FOR SIX YEARS AND
YOU ARE SEPARATED FOR A LONG
TIME.
>> IN '71 THERE WAS A BIG
UPRISING AMONGST US AND
JOHN McCAIN -- EVEN THOUGH BUD
DAY WAS THE SENIOR MANAGER,
JOHN McCAIN WAS CREDITED WITH
BEING THE LEADER OF THAT.
AND IN FACT, ON MARCH 19TH THEY
TOOK 36 OF US OUT, WE HONESTLY
THOUGHT WE WERE BEING TAKEN OUT
TO BE EXECUTED AND JOHN McCAIN
MADE A JOKE ABOUT IT.
A MAN WHO CAN VOLUNTEER TO DIE
FOR RELIGIOUS FREEDOM, THAT'S
WHAT IT WAS AND MAKE A JOKE
ABOUT IT IS REALLY A TOP GUY.
I HOLD HIM ALMOST THE SAME
STATUS AS JAMES STOCKDALE.
>> Laura: WOW.
TO JUST HEAR THE STORIES.
>> HE WOULDN'T GO HOME.
THEY SAID TO HIM GO HOME, BUT
BECAUSE -- IN TERMS OF BEING
CAPTURED, HE REFUSED AND SO THEY
BEAT HIM FOR IT.
THOSE THAT ARE CRITICAL OF HIM
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE HOW HE
HAS VOTED ON CERTAIN ISSUES, WHO
AMONG US IN THIS STUDIO WOULD
GIVE OUR LEGS, ARMS, OUR BODY,
OUR LIVES?
>> Laura: HE ALSO SAID I THINK
AT ONE TIME, I WAS A P.O.W. BUT
WE CAN DISAGREE.
JOHN KERRY SERVED HIS COUNTRY